logic we use the word logic and words
derived from that same Greek root logos
in a variety of ways you've probably
said that someone was being illogical
because they were too emotional or
didn't agree with you you might have
thought of logic as a way of proving
things or reasoning better
I plan to dig a little deeper and talk
about logic is one basic way to approach
our use of language for starters that
means I'd like to distinguish between
logic as a way of talking about thinking
especially reasoning and truth and logic
as a way of talking about language and
what goes into using language I don't
need to propose this division as a hard
and Exceptionalist rule but however you
plan to use logic as long as you're
communicating with other humans your
basic starting point will be logic as a
way to analyze language but since the
systems we use to communicate analysis
are themselves languages that means
we'll have to consider logic itself as a
language this short series will
introduce logic as a language more
specifically I'll present logic as a
formal language formal not because it's
more polite but because it focuses on
form instead of meaning before getting
into the basics consider what I I will
and will not cover in this series you
will get to consider logic as a language
see how to translate into that language
and look at symbolic logic as a kind of
backbone model for the fuller statements
made in everyday language I won't spend
time analyzing good or bad arguments you
know syllogisms and formal informal
fallacies and the like I won't discuss
inductive versus deductive reasoning and
will consider admittedly important
questions like does logic underlie both
language in reality one of the various
types of logics and how do they relate
to or different from each other or apply
the logic of the language of logic to
any particular field
on with the basics I through the terms
logic and language out at you I know
those are abstract terms but think about
learning a new language a language
spoken in some foreign country if you
reflect for a moment on the components
of that language you'll have to take on
new sounds new parts of words the
specific words used in that language the
meaning of those new words and the rules
for constructing well-formed phrases and
sentences one way to simplify all this
is by trying to find some core concept
we might imagine that speakers use
language to convey things to listeners
for example when I tell you about a
house you might think of something very
much like this so the word house acts as
a symbol for this here we took words as
our core concept and said that words are
symbols but it looks like words aren't
just symbols they're fixed symbols with
specific definitions when you parse the
word house you related the word to a
single concept the word house and other
words act like constant symbols or
constants one key feature of these
constants like house dog and blue is
that they have semantic value there
they're meaningful these meaningful
constants constants can relate to one
another in a variety of ways to broaden
basic relationships our intention and
extension intention refers to what
occurred connotes other words commonly
associated with that word or other words
that are properties of that word this
connotes house red and so on extension
is what it word denotes its definition
or its examples for example house
extends to this of course we don't just
speak in single words we also make
statements like the house is red or fish
can swim and those statements are
meaningful so we would consider those
symbols - so far it follows that those
statements would also work like
constants but now we're taking on so
many symbols all kinds of things all
kinds of sentences we can say about
things
all of these are symbols it would be
hard to count all of them let alone as
little and analyze all of them
what if we could strip language down to
just the symbols that's the aim of
symbolic logic we want a set of symbols
that helps us evaluate structure without
getting tethered in the meaning and the
use we may still want constants but
we'll definitely need symbols that
aren't so fixed since their meanings
wouldn't be fixed
these symbols would vary so they're
called variables to make it easy on
ourselves we'll use very simple symbols
for variables like X we can use these
variables for words this X can mean a
house but it's not limited to that value
it might mean a dog it might also
represent an entire statement this house
is red or I'm speaking English these
symbols will help us strip out our
language down and take a good look at
the structure for variables I can use
symbols like X Y & Z for statements with
some truth value it's common to use P
and Q these are all conventions of
course in concrete cases you will want
to use a symbol that helps you make
sense of the logical form say e when
you're exclusively reading E as the
English language or English in this case
you're using that symbol as an
individual constant a name with the
specific interpretation well that's
background for the upcoming videos in
the next lesson I'll talk about subjects
and predicates I'll also use variables
and constants to take a look at the
logic behind some normal language
sentences using formal logic